all right so i wanted to do this video
on what i actually eat on a given day
now the reason why i'm hesitant to do this video
is simply because um it's nothing exciting and um
you know i'm not your average person i can eat
the same thing every single day my wife has to
have variety i don't i primarily eat for health
most people don't eat for health so realize when i
tell you this this is just what i eat you can eat
whatever you want to eat just make sure it's keto
friendly when most people start keto they do need
desserts they need variety to keep it interesting
so realize this is just a kind of a an example
of what i eat now presently i eat one and a half
meals a day i'm going to tell you why i would
normally eat one meal a day but if i do that i
tend to lose a little too much weight and it's
very difficult for me to consume the amount of
calories in one meal so i kind of spread it out so
it's not two full meals it's like one and a half
the first meal is between one to two o'clock okay
in the afternoon and the second meal is between
five and six o'clock p.m so that gives me kind of
a fasting range between 19 hours and 21 hours now
i also want to differentiate the difference
between keto and healthy keto keto basically
is just low carbs they're not focused on the
nutrition okay the nutrients the benefit is from
the lowering of your carbs healthy keto factors
in the nutrient-dense foods okay and this is why i
recommend the healthy keto plan with this x factor
called intermittent fasting seems to work great
on pretty much everyone all right what do i eat in
the first meal i consume a combination of protein
and fat mostly some vegetables but not too much i
may do four eggs with onions with some fermented
veggies and so i get these fermented veggies from
the farmer's market sometimes i get them from
amazon and make sure that they don't have sugar
in them i might also do asparagus and i'll just
have that raw and i'll just chew on like
maybe five uh five little stalks of asparagus
now realize someone took my video out of context
and they said dr berg eats all this food in one
meal which is not true so when i give you these
examples you're not supposed to add them up okay
i don't eat all of these this is four eggs onions
slash fermented vegetables or hamburger half a
pound but not both together okay so i just want to
clarify that now i consume a lot of hamburger why
because hamburger is a lot more fatty than steak
and i never buy the 90 lean i buy the 75 to 80
so it's more fatty i'll consume about half a pound
with sauerkraut so that would be my protein i make
sure that it's grass-fed grass-finished and a
bit fatty i do buy a lot of my hamburger from u.s
wellness meats i don't get any commission off that
fyi now another option i might consume especially
if i'm in a rush is summer sausage i found one
that has less than one gram of sugar okay and i
put the link down below it's pretty good and it's
all organic so that's good it's very hard to find
summer sausage without having some dextrose or
other types of sugar in it and i'll i will consume
about eight ounces of that okay it's very fast
i'll cut it up and sometimes i'll add cheese to it
maybe i'll have some swiss cheese the cheese
is always grass-fed organic and primarily from
europe it's not velveeta okay now other times
i'll have some salmon i'm very very spoiled
with salmon because sometimes you get this salmon
that's old or it's um if you go to a restaurant
it's overcooked and it just doesn't taste that
great so i make my own salmon and i just fry it
with olive oil put sea salt and pepper and
then i'll put mayo i like the primal kitchen
mail because it doesn't have any sugar and the
oil is avocado oil and that's what i'll consume
and sometimes i'll add olives to my meal i like
olives so that's pretty much what i eat now right
after the meal i might add some pecans because
i might not be satisfied so maybe a handful of
pecans sometimes i'll do celery and peanut
butter the peanut butter is organic valencia
salted i get that from trader joe's i've done
videos on that it's a pretty good peanut butter
and sometimes i'll add a little chocolate
now of course this is sugar-free chocolate
there's a lot of different keto friendly chocolate
things out there the one that i like now is just
with chocolate and stevia i'll put a link down
below of a few you may not like these because
when you sweeten chocolate with stevia it gives
you this little aftertaste which i don't seem to
mind karen won't consume it so she does lily's
chocolate which is a little bit tastier but i
find that that throws off my digestive system
if i have chocolate with just stevia it doesn't
bother my digestive system at all and i'll
just do like three ounces of that chocolate
okay so now that's the simplicity of what i eat
for my first meal second meal all right i will
primarily start with the veggies okay usually
eight cups of salad sometimes seven sometimes ten
but it's this bowl of salad i'll start eating
that i like to use arugula or a greens mix
from the farmer's market simply because sometimes
the salad that you buy at the grocery store is
just completely empty the ideal situation would
be to have you consume salad from your own garden
i'm going to do some videos on that that would be
the best thing because you can control how much
nutrition that's in that salad i really believe
that people do not like salad because they've
never tasted really good salad grown on really
good soils so i highly recommend you seek out some
good salad so you can taste what it normally
should taste like okay now i put some sea salt
on my salad i might add avocado maybe some
nuts but not too many other things i use a
lot of olive oil but not your regular olive oil
i get my olive oil from italy i'm sure there's
other types of olive oil out there but just make
sure it's fresh because most the olive oil out
there doesn't even taste like anything it should
have a very fresh almost like a grass-cut taste
kind of a little spicy so i just dump a lot
of olive oil on there and i'll put balsamic
vinaigrette okay that's all i use now
i may have a different type of salad
uh chopped cabbage and carrot okay and i use
a combination of white cabbage and red cabbage
i have one of those little choppers that
i just put in there and i chop it down
and if i'm doing that i'm not gonna do eight
cups i'm gonna do like three and a half cups
because it's very dense and i'll put
some mayo on it from primal kitchen
and i just love that that seems to really
digest well and that would be my vegetable for
the day now sometimes i might just do a steamed
cauliflower four cups with a lot of butter and
sea salt and pepper all right do i add any protein
occasionally sometimes i'll do like a half a can
of cod liver not cod liver oil but cod liver you
can search it it's out there it's pretty awesome
most of it's wild caught and it's not bad tasting
and it's very high in fat and it has some protein
in there not too much if you do a whole can of
cod liver you're going to be very filled up and
sometimes i do that as well depending on if i've
exercised very intensely and i need to eat more
now i also might add some summer sausage not eight
ounces but maybe four ounces okay it's really
quick it gives me a little protein and maybe
i'll put a little swiss cheese with that i may
add some pecans i may add celery with that peanut
butter i mentioned um just until i'm satisfied
okay so that's pretty much what i eat now what
do i fry the eggs in beef tallow where do i get
my greens preferably from the farmer's market
if i can sometimes i can't go there so i will
just buy the arugula from the store it has to be
organic of course and when tomatoes are in season
i will consume a tremendous amount of tomatoes
from the farmer's market or i will consume them
from the garden but i will not consume a tomato
unless it's a good tasting one which means that
it has a lot of nutrition all right guys so there
you have it that's what i eat pretty boring but
it's workable hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why here's you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about here
what about strengthening your immune system
that's what's missing this course will show
you how to bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist your environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today